mariah risa ha sido acusada de fraude y
de evasión de impuestos e incluso de
recibir dinero de las tías ha sido
declarada culpable por difamación y
podría pasar años en la cárcel pero
también es la ganadora conjunta del
premio nobel de la paz de este año
gracias a lo que el comité del nobel
llamó su valiente lucha por la libertad
de expresión en filipinas ha sido una
piedra del zapato del presidente
rodríguez verde y a través de su medio
de noticias digitales robert ha señalado
la corrupción del gobierno y la brutal
guerra contra las drogas llevada a cabo
por el país todo mientras se enfrenta
una campaña que busca silenciar la no
sólo a ella sino también al rápido me
complace anunciar que nos acompaña hoy
envió desde manila mar ya reza es un
gran placer tenerla aquí en france 24
gracias por su tiempo y felicitaciones
gracias y gracias por haberme invitado
ha pasado casi una semana desde que
recibió esa llamada anunciando que este
año recibiría de manera conjunta el
premio de la paz cómo ha sido esta
última semana
todavia no sigo sorprendida pero hablar
con periodistas de todas partes del
mundo ha sido una experiencia
maravillosa
experience hemos pasado por unos 5 años
muy difíciles
pero esta mañana estuve hablando con
editores de venezuela we were se
encuentra aún más abajo que filipinas en
el inicio de la libertad de prensa
estable con editores en indonesia y en y
de lo que me he dado cuenta es que
cuando el comité del nobel escogió darle
el nobel de este año a los periodistas
fue para el conjunto
para todos los periodistas en el mundo
hace un rato usted me preguntó es más
peligroso es más difícil es todo eso
es tan solo hacer lo que los periodistas
han hecho siempre es más peligroso
requiere más sacrificios
imagino que ha recibido felicitaciones
de todas partes del mundo en los últimos
seis días pero tal vez no esperaba
recibir las del presidente de su propio
país rodrigo duterte él ha llevado a
cabo una especie de vendetta en su
contra y en contra de la organización
rapper pero a través de su portavoz
declaró que su victoria es una gran
victoria para filipinas como se sintió
cuando los hecho decir eso
y esa mañana uno de nuestros
presentadores locales me preguntó si yo
lo estaba esperando y yo dije que eso
sería profesional en especial porque el
presidente putin el kremlin ya habían
felicitado dmitri y creo que fue de
doble filo porque la primera frase fue
esa y luego en la siguiente habló de los
procesos legales
los cuales como firmamos mis abogados y
yo contienen muchos acrobacias legales
como la ciber de información por ejemplo
fui declarada culpable con un antiguo
colega por un crimen que no existió
cuando publicamos en 2012 una historia
que yo no escribí no edite ni supervise
el periodo de prescripción por
difamación era de un año
pienso que corregimos las percepciones
erróneas pero estoy contenta supongo nos
alegramos mucho por usted felicitaciones
de nuevo me interesa saber qué tipo de
impacto piensa que puede tener esta
victoria en su trabajo en filipinas ya
mencionó los grandes retos que enfrenta
a nivel personal me pregunto qué impacto
puede tener la atención que está
recibiendo ahora les facilitará el
trabajo a su equipo
le preocupa que esto pueda intensificar
la campaña de facal en el estamento está
claramente dirigida contra usted
no es sólo digital este es mi trigésimo
quinto año como periodista y en menos de
dos años el gobierno filipino expide los
diez órdenes de arresto en mi contra y
nunca había vivido algo así en 2018
cuando la revista 'time' me escogió para
una de las portadas como personaje del
año me impactó mucho porque al igual que
con el nobel no sabía que eso pasaría y
cuando pasó pensé que la situación
empeoraría y al final terminó
construyendo un escudo a mi alrededor y
alrededor del rapel esta atención que el
comité del nobel osado en filipinas le
dio un estímulo de adrenalina no sólo a
mí a rapper sino a todos los periodistas
aquí en especial ahora que nos
preparamos para las elecciones
presidenciales cruciales que tendrán
lugar en mayo pero hay un problema la
última vez que un periodista ha recibido
este prestigioso premio fue en los años
1930 y ese periodista la en dirección
los campos de concentración nazis y
murió por complicaciones debido a la
tortura
y le dije lo siguiente a mi equipo
durante la reunión que tuvimos después
si es un momento para celebrar puesto
que las cosas podrían mejorar
pero como siempre amo durante los
últimos cinco años debemos estar
preparados para que las cosas empeoren y
debemos seguir haciendo nuestro trabajo
y es optimista en que será posible ver
un cambio una vez de perth evans donde
poder mencionó las elecciones que se
llevarán a cabo la próxima primavera
constitucionalmente él no puede
participar en las elecciones podría
hacer esto el comienzo de fin de una era
esta mano dura aplicar abierta de prensa
que usted ha vivido
y yo lo pienso como si fueran termitas
comiendo madera
la madera se ve muy sólida pero al
pisarlas se rompe se quiebra si uno se
cae en
los montes mantenido el poder en la
ciudad de dávao desde 1988 vidrios ya
han usado un vacío legal para que los
filipinos siempre tengan dudas después
de haber presentado los certificados de
candidatura
eso terminó el pasado viernes pero ahora
a causa de un vacío legal que utilizaron
en el pasado que él utilizó en 2016 que
es la sustitución tendremos que esperar
hasta el 15 de noviembre para saber
quiénes son los candidatos finales para
presidente y vicepresidente
creo que el problema es que nuestras
elecciones eran una batalla por los
hechos las plataformas de redes sociales
estadounidenses esas empresas
estadounidenses jugarán un papel
esencial si no establecen un límite en
la difusión algorítmica eso por un lado
lo segundo es saber son nuestras
instituciones se recuperarán durante los
seis meses del primer año era posible
verlas desplomarse internamente y estos
procesos legales que se están
enfrentando y que rösler está
enfrentando en un momento normal
cinco años no se habrían llevado a los
tribunales pero ahora estamos luchando
en los tribunales así que creo que hay
una especie de rejuvenecimiento de las
instituciones
usted alude a lo que ha pasado alrededor
de facebook en las últimas semanas en
particular en eeuu donde a una
extrabajadora está acusando a la
compañía de poner las ganancias por
encima de las necesidades de enfrentar
la desinformación y piensa que esto
mismo está pasando en filipinas haciendo
de los pinos
es lo que está pasando en todas partes
del mundo donde nosotros alertamos sobre
esto
en 2016 exigimos anti impunidad para el
presidente desperté y su brutal guerra
contra las drogas
en week y para mark zuckerberg y
facebook
y seguimos exigiendo la porque no ha
habido verdaderos cambios positivos en
ninguno de estos hombres fuertes
en las organizaciones que dirigen y creo
que el problema que tenemos aquí es que
las redes sociales facebook que es el
mayor distribuidor de noticias del mundo
está gobernado por algoritmos que en
realidad
a través de esa investigación se ve que
difunde mentiras mezcladas con rabia y
odio
más rápido y más lejos que los hechos
mismos ahí es donde están las noticias
nuestras noticias son distribuidas a
través de una plataforma sesgada contra
los hechos y sesgada contra los
periodistas si los hechos no se puede
tener la verdad
si la verdad no se puede tener confianza
sin confianza nada es posible y eso
lleva a preguntarse tal vez sobre el
porqué de un premio por la paz porque
los hechos son el principio de cualquier
acción más gorda si no restablecemos eso
tratar de lidiar con problemas
existenciales como el coronavirus o el
cambio climático o la lucha por la
verdad será imposible de hacer debemos
ponerle un límite a la tecnología y todo
esto parece haberse empeorado durante la
época de donde el trump en eeuu pero
donald trump obviamente ya no está en la
administración y también está vetado en
las redes sociales
actualmente le han cortado la lengua
me pregunto si usted cree que esto
seguirá ahora que a donald trump hands
presidente o sin tarde tal vez deja
desde el presidente o le preocupa que el
debate haya cambiado de manera
fundamental incluso aunque en sus
salidas demagogos ya dicen en el poder
el mundo ha cambiado de manera
fundamental piénselo de esta manera
aunque trump está temporalmente fuera de
facebook y también el tono en su
discurso público en eeuu el president
traductor te ha cambiado el tono del
discurso en nosotros contra ellos ese
tipo de liderazgo divisorio que funciona
muy bien en las redes sociales
which out que margina a otros y manipula
la opinión de los demás no creo que ese
problema haya terminado y eso es lo que
más temen ellas el biólogo
estadounidense ian wilson se dijo que la
mayor crisis que estamos enfrentando
ahora son nuestras emociones
paleolíticas nuestras instituciones
medievales y nuestra tecnología divina
la tecnología divina es casi como si se
liberara un virus de mentiras en el
ecosistema de la información
todo el mundo se contagia de este virus
de mentiras y las personas cambian sus
visiones del mundo y luego cambio en su
manera de actuar
un perfecto ejemplo de esto es el 6 de
enero esa violencia en el capitolio esa
meta narrativa detengan el road
se sembró un año antes en rt y luego fue
retomada por el líbano en youtube
y se distribuyó por páginas privadas y
luego fue retomada por carson en fox
antes de ser retomada por cubano para
luego finalmente acabar llegando al
presidente
detengan el robo esa es la meta
narrativa que se ha utilizado en mi
contra los periodistas equivalen a
criminales eso se utiliza en filipinas
contra los periodistas y se sembró en
andahuasi de dentón y sixty jarabes
kendrick a mi me declararon culpable y
todavía lo estoy apelando en 2020 esto
no ha terminado y a las personas a
quienes les camino la mentalidad les
tomará mucho tiempo es un sesgo
cognitivo las redes sociales se han
convertido en un sistema que modifica el
comportamiento y nosotros nos hemos
convertido en los perros de pavlov y
esos parados
como lo mencionó usted realmente ha
sentido las consecuencias de esto
incluso está enfrentando una posible
condena con tiempo de cárcel me interesa
mucho que nos pueden dar un poco acerca
de esto ha sido periodista durante los
últimos 35 años que la motivó a hacer
este trabajo tan retador
en algún momento en el que pensara bueno
la presión sobre mí y sobre mi familia
es demasiada tal vez necesito renunciar
a hacer otras cosas
me encanta el periodismo me enamoré del
periodismo bien creo que crecí en la
época dorada del periodismo
fui parte del último grupo de
corresponsales extranjeros
un tiempo increíble para aprender es una
prueba para estar físicas mental
emocional y espiritualmente en todos los
frentes
creamos rapear en 2012 porque sabíamos
que el futuro del periodismo está ligado
a la tecnología
estaba dirigiendo el mayor grupo
mediático de filipinas
es muy difícil cambiar el legado de un
grupo mediático porque los procesos y la
cultura se interpondrán así que fundar
rapper era mejor
cuando el gobierno los atacó en 2016 yo
ya sabía por qué hacia lo que hacía
estaba al final de mi carrera y cuando
enfrentas una pruebas como esa estás
hecho de los valores que dices tener o
no lo estás así que al principio ni
siquiera lo pensé los pasos que debió
tomar
y denunciarlos enfrentarme al poder y
luego cuando me detuvieron y me
arrestaron durante la noche porque
querían que yo sintiera su poder ahí
experimenté de primera mano cómo se
abusa del fútbol
y con el tiempo seguir reuniendo más
evidencia de primera mano siempre se
tiene miedo usted me dice que soy muy
valiente no se trata de ser valiente
se trata de controlar el miedo y luego
de darse cuenta porque hacemos lo que
hacemos los periodistas en el mundo
creo que eso es lo que el comité del
nobel también resaltó
la misión del periodismo que hace
responsable al poder llevando la verdad
al público
somos representantes del público al que
servimos esa misión nunca ha sido tan
importante como lo es ahora
varias risas antes de ir las quiero
hacerle una última pregunta
y tratar algunas críticas que recibió el
comité del nobel este año porque usted
es la única mujer en haber sido nominada
este año para un premio nobel en el
pasado creo que en total sólo 18 mujeres
han recibido premios nobel usted ha
dicho que no reuters han hecho un
esfuerzo para contratar mujeres es esa
una prioridad particular para usted si
cree que es un fracaso en la industria
del periodismo el hecho de que no
tengamos mujeres ocupando altos cargos
y creo que es cultural y creo que es
levemente distinto en cada nación en
filipinas ha habido mujeres directoras
por temporadas y el rápido somos un 63%
de mujeres y
nuestro promedio de edad es de 23 años
así que son los jóvenes
esa es la de promedio en filipinas
creo que el movimiento feministas muchos
pasos hacia adelante
pero la tecnología lo ha hecho
retroceder de nuevo al empoderar el
surgimiento de este tipo de líderes como
duterte como trump como mencionaron
hay un rasgo sexista macho y misógino
que le da permiso a otros en la sociedad
para volverse la peor versión de sí
mismos
y de manera inevitable cuando nos
fijamos en los datos que tenemos en
filipinas las mujeres periodistas son
atacadas al menos 10 veces más que los
hombres
eso sea similar en términos del nobel es
difícil
no se puede establecer una cuando yo era
una minoría cuando estaba en el colegio
en eeuu
al entrar bajo un programa de minorías
uno piensa realmente lo merezco o lo
conseguí por ser una minoría
eso sería una pregunta posible creo que
debemos movernos de manera colectiva en
1995 en la conferencia de mujeres de
beijing se establecieron una serie de
principios
y el mundo iba a tratar de trabajar por
ellos fue un momento de mucho optimismo
logramos algunas cosas pero todavía
queda mucho por hacer y creo que lo
primero que debemos hacer es ponerle un
límite a la tecnología para que las
mujeres puedan reclamar su espacio son
muchas mujeres periodistas y muchas
políticas se han retirado de la escena
hay que traerlas de regreso y luego
haremos avanzar las culturas
maria riesch haciendo se acabó el tiempo
ha sido un placer tenerla para france24
muchas gracias por su tiempo maria
riesch ha ganado ahora el premio nobel
de la paz hablando aquí con nosotros
mismos